infektion isoliert und in der folge
hatte auch alle länder die in schulen
die das bundesland geschlossen oder wert
ist in kürze tun die er gemeinsam mit
den ländern weitere leiten für das
allgemeine verhalten gesprochen
das rettet uns dabei dass es immer
wieder schon der wissenschaft gesagt
wird nämlich dass die wirksamste
maßnahme um diese infektion zu
verringern
das erhöhen der distanz des abstandes
ist also dass es verringern von sozialen
kontakten und wir wollen natürlich was
können die wirtschaftlichen prozessen
soweit möglich und ausdrücklich das
internet erhalten garantieren dass die
medizinische versorgung gewährleistet
werden dass die energieversorgung in der
letzte test dass die ernährung
die band ist und sind dass ein großer
teil einer dienstleistung in anspruch
genommen werden kann und wer doch
brauchen wir einschreiten hat
das infektionsgeschehen wie so oft schon
gesagt zu verlangsamen
das sind massen
unser land so noch nicht gegeben hat
natürlich rheinstetten sind aber sie
sind im augenblick notwendig und die
sozialen kontakte zellen ziehen damit
sie braucht und für erkrankungen und
auch die zahl der schweren erkrankungen
reduziert und es ist eben nicht zu wort
kommen
das ist einfach großartig ist was wir
heute gemeinsam besprochen haben wir die
bundesländern und zum größten teil die
überwiegend durch die müngstener noch
umzusetzen sie werden das in kürze tun
wenn sie es nicht zu rechnen haben
aber unsere alle sehr wichtig dass wir
einen großen garten einheitlich jetzt an
im internet braucht 2000 darunter
besonders sind möchte ich sie auch hier
heute einmal in den vortrag
ich beginne mit dem was ausdrücklich
nicht geschlossen
das wäre sehr wichtig die nicht
geschlossen wird der einzelne
lebensmittelmärkte abholen lieferdienste
getränkemärkte apotheken sanitätshäuser
drogerien tankstellen banken und
sparkassen poststellen versuchen
[Musik]
und der großhandel
vielmehr sollten für diese von mir jetzt
genannten bereiche sogar überlegt werden
ob wir die sonntags verkaufsverbote bis
auf weiteres grundsätzlich aussetzen und
eine öffnung dieser genannten
einrichtungen erfolgt natürlich unter
auflagen zur hygiene zur steuerung des
zutritts und zur vermeidung von
warteschlangen dienstleister und
handwerker können ihrer tätigkeit weiter
nachgehen und alle einrichtungen des
gesundheitswesens bleiben unter
beachtung der gestiegenen hygienischen
anforderungen geöffnet das sind die
dinge die wichtig sind dass sie weiter
von den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
anspruch genommen werden könnten
zweitens für den publikumsverkehr zu
schließen sind bars clubs diskotheken
kneipen und ähnliche einrichtungen
theater- opern- konzert- häuser museen
und ähnliche einrichtungen messen
ausstellungen kinos freizeit und
tierparks und anbieter von
freizeitaktivitäten sowohl innen als
auch außen spezialmärkte spielhallen
spielbanken wettannahmestellen und
ähnliche einrichtungen
prostitutionsstätten modelle und
ähnliche einrichtungen der sportbetrieb
auf und in allen öffentlichen und
privaten sportanlagen schwimmen und
spaßbädern fitnessstudios und ähnlichen
eindruck einrichtungen alle weiteren
nicht ansteht an anderer stelle in
diesem papier genannten verkaufsstellen
des einzelhandels insbesondere auch
outlet center und spielplätze das sind
also die dinge die geschlossen werden
drittens zu verbieten sind
zusammenkünfte in vereinen und sonstigen
sport und freizeiteinrichtungen sowie
die wahrnehmung von angebotenen
volkshochschulen musikschulen und
sonstigen öffentlichen und privaten
bildungseinrichtungen im
außerschulischen bereich sowie reisebus
reisen zusätzlich zusammenkünfte in
kirchen moscheen
synagogen und die zusammenkünfte anderer
glaubensgemeinschaften und viertens zu
erlassen sind besuchsregelung für
krankenhäuser vorsorge und
rehabilitationseinrichtungen pflegeheime
und besondere wohnformen im sinne des
sozialgesetzbuchs 14 sowie ähnliche
einrichtungen um den besuch zu
beschränken
zum beispiel besuch einmal am tag für
eine stunde allerdings nicht von kindern
unter 16 jahren und vor allen dingen
nicht von besuchern mit
atemwegsinfektionen in den vorgenannten
einrichtungen sowie in universitäten
schulen und kindergärten soweit ihren
betrieb nicht gänzlich eingestellt wird
ein generelles betretungsverbot für
personen die sich in den letzten 14
tagen in risikogebieten im ausland oder
besonders betroffene regionen im inland
nach lkw klassifizierung aufgehalten
haben auflagen für menschen restaurants
speisegaststätten und hotels das risiko
einer verbreiterung des corona virus zu
minimieren etwa durch abstandsregelung
für die tische reglementierung der
besucherzahl hygienemaßnahmen und
hygiene hinweise regelungen das
übernachtungsangebote im inland nur zur
notwendigen und ausdrücklich nicht zu
touristischen zwecken genutzt werden
können
das beinhaltet und bringt mit sich auch
dass es keine urlaubsreisen ins in- und
auch keine ins ausland geben soll
regelungen dass restaurants und
speisegaststätten generell frühestens ab
6 uhr morgens geöffnet sind und
spätestens ab 18 uhr zu schließen sind
wir haben diese beschlüsse nach
intensiven abstimmung und beratungen
gefasst und sie verändern natürlich für
eine bestimmte zeit unseren alltag immer
mit dem ziel kontakte zu minimieren
dinge zu verlangsamen und kontakte zu
vermeiden
wir wissen dass unsere politik nur
wirksam sein kann wenn wir das zwischen
bund und
dann also zwischen allen ebenen unseres
landes gut abstimmen und mit gleicher
entschlossenheit vorgehen und ich bin
sehr dankbar dass diese übereinkunft mit
den ländern heute in einer so
konstruktiven atmosphäre gefunden werden
könnte ich habe eben auch die
fraktionsvorsitzenden der im deutschen
bundestag vertretenen fraktionen über
die maßnahmen unterrichtet und
zusätzlich gab es heute noch
internationale aktivitäten hätte früher
eine video-konferenz mit der
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen und dem ratspräsidenten star
michelle dem französischen präsidenten
emanuel makro und mir
wir haben darin auch eine morgige video
konferenz der staats und regierungschefs
vorbereitet und haben über die frage
gesprochen die die binnengrenzen
kontrollen besser koordiniert werden
können deutschland und frankreich waren
hier in abstimmung aber an vielen
stellen ist das nicht abgestimmt erfolgt
und die eu kommission hat heute auch ein
reiseverbot lassen von für einreisen von
bürgerinnen und bürgern aus ländern die
nicht der eu nicht dem öfter bereich und
nicht großbritannien angehören
auch für 30 tage so analog zu dem was
wir zum beispiel gegenüber der
europäischen union auch von den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
anderen ländern schon gesehen haben
wir haben heute nachmittag dort wurde
das auch verkündet bereits eine g7
video-konferenz gehabt mit den staats
und regierungschefs der g 7 länder dort
hat die kommissionspräsidentin dies auch
deutlich gemacht diese maßnahmen des
reise bands also das einreiseverbot für
30 tage müssen von den nationalstaaten
den mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union umgesetzt werden das werden wir
tun aber wir haben auch über die
aktivitäten von g7 gesprochen und haben
uns geeinigt dass wir koordiniert und im
engen austausch vorgehen wollen dass wir
die wichtige rolle der
weltgesundheitsorganisation noch einmal
unterstrichen haben wenn wir ein
bekenntnis zum zur wichtigkeit des
globalen handels abgegeben und wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass wir in diesem
austausch auch weiter sehr
intensiv bleiben werden nicht nur die
staats und regierungschefs sondern auch
die gesundheitsminister und auch die
minister im bereich von finanzen und
wirtschaft herzlichen dank